يلا رحبوا معانا بالمتحدث الملهم الدكتور
فائز
مليباري
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته انا هنا اليوم عشان احدثكم عن شخص
كنت حابب انه هو يكون هنا بنفسه يتكلم
ولكن هو لا يزال طفل صغير عمره اربع
سنوات الطفل هذا هو ابني
عباده عباده هو اصغر شخص في عائلتي وهو اخ
صغير لملك اخته وعمرها خمس
سنوات
جاء عباد على حياتنا وملى علينا حياتنا
بابتسامته ابتسامته المشعه السعيده دائما
وغير علينا حياتنا وكنت انا اشوفه كل يوم
وهو بيكبر بيننا وهو سعيد وطموح ونشيط كنت
اقول الطفل هذا حيغير علينا حياتنا ويغير
العالم وانا ما كنت داري ايش معنى هذا
الموضوع ولكن هو بالفعل غير علي حياتي ف
في يوم من الايام انا كنت في كنا في اجازه
وزرنا طبيب الاطفال زياره
روتينيه والدكتور شافه وطلب مجموعه تحاليل
قال انا ماني مطمن عليه قلنا خير ان شاء
الله يلا خلينا نشوف ايش في عمل تحليل ما
اطمن قال لا لازم نوديه الطوارئ ودينا
الطوارئ من الطوارئ دخل على تنويم ععد يوم
يومين تحليل ورا تحليل ثلاثه اربع ايام
ونحنا في حاله من الغموض ما احنا عارفين
ايش اللي
بيصير عد اسبوع وبعدها عرفنا الخبر والحمد
لله تم تشخيص ابني عباده بمرض اللوكيميا
طبعا اللوكيميا للي ما يعرف هو مرض سرطان
في الدم بحيث انه الخلايا النخاعيه اللي
في جسم الانسان في العظم اللي بتنتج
الخلايا الدمويه الحمراء والبيضاء وغيره
بتنتج خلايا سرطانيه تهاجم الجسم ويحتاج
مريض اللوكيميا الى العلاج الكيميائي حتاج
في بعض الحالات يحتاج العلاج الاشعاعي
الحمد لله وجدنا نفسنا في ضغط نفسي شديد
جدا
وللامانه
يعني ام عباده كانت اقوى مني في تقبل
الخبر انا انا ادمرت ودخلت في حاله من
يعني من التضارب النفسي وليش يا ربي وليه
طيب ابني عمره ثلاث سنوات ما اذى احد ليش
مو انا وكانت يعني كانت حاله صعبه جدا
وانا عرفت انه لازم اخرج من هذا الموضوع
باي طريقه ولا انا هدمر
فعمل شويه قرارات اولها كان اني انا ما
حغير على العباده حياته ابدا فستت اروح
اروح للمستشفى واقعد معاه وهو منوم اقرا
له كتابه الون له الوانه العب معاه في
العابه عباده بدا يقول ابغى ملك ابغى اشوف
اختي فكان عباده يشتاق لاخته يقول ابغى
اشوف اختي فكنت اروح اجيب له عبا اخته وكل
شيء الحمد لله عدت اول فتره من العلاج
اللي كان فيها هو منوم وراح البيت وقالوا
لا هوو خلاص يقدر يزورنا كل يوم ياخذ جرعه
العلاج ويرجع للبيت قلنا الحمد
لله لما صار العلاج من البيت يعني كنا
ظننا انه الموضوع حخف لكن للاسف اكتشفنا
انه لا تقريبا نحنا صرنا بنقضي حياتنا
كلها في الطوارئ لانه مع العلاج بتجي له
حمه وكل حمى لمريض السرطان لازم يتم
تحليلها
فكنا بنقضي تقريبا من سته الى ثمان ساعات
كل يوم في الطوارئ اضطرت ام عباده انها
تترك عملها لفتره مفتوحه ترافق
ابني طبعا يعني ظننا انه الموضوع حيكون
اخف من كده ولكن للاسف الموضوع يعني كل
ماله كان بيصير اصعب وانا كل مالي يعني
تحت ضغط قوي جدا وكنت لازم الاقي لي متنفس
اني اروح عن نفسي عشان لا يصير في شيء
فاتجهت الى السوشيال ميديا او الوسائط
الاجتماعيه وبدات اكتب عن
عباده وسميته عباده البطل لسبب واحد عباده
رغم كل اللي عدى فيه هذا وكل الوجه اللي
نحنا فيه كانت ابتسامته لا تفارق
وجهه فسميته عباد البطل وبدات اتكلم عن
عباد البطل في السوشيال
ميديا لما بدا العلاج شعره بدا يتساقط فما
كنا حابين انه هو يشوف شعره يتساقط خذله
ما يصحى من النوم فقلنا له حبيبي احنا
نحلق لك شعرك ما قال عنده ما كان عنده
مشكله راح وحلنا له شعره وكل حاجه وكان
مبسوط بشكله الجديد وبيطول في نفسه في
المرايا وكل حاجه
وكذا انتهى
اليوم انتهى هذاك اليوم وخلاص قبل ما ينام
قاللي مامات يلا خلاص الحفله انتهت يلا
ماما رجعيلي
شعري حبيبي شعرك ما حيرجع لا الا ترجعو لي
شعري بالطول بالعرض ما وبدا يبكي وابغى
شعري وما اعرف ايش
فان كانت رده فعلي الفوريه اني رحت للحمام
واخذت ماكينه الحلاقه وحلقت شعري وقلت له
شوف وقلت له شوف حبيبي يعني شعرك ما حيرجع
لكن انت الان شكلك صار زي بابا هو شاف
شكله زي بابا قال خلاص انا كده مبسوط اذا
انا شكلي زي بابا انا
سعيد وعدت وعدت هذه الفتره ولكن في
المرحله الثانيه من العلاج اضطرينا نحلق
لله شعر المره الثانيه وفي هذيك المره هو
قاوم تماما ورفض قال لا انا ما ابغى اخسر
شعري مره ثانيه وقاوم يسعك ويرضيك ما ما
في فايده فجاتني فكره ثانيه انا قلت له
ايش رايك تخليني احلق لك شعرك واخليك انت
تحلق لي
شعري
طبعا طبعا قام وجري على الحمام وتحمس وغير
ملابسه وكل حاجه وخلاني احلق له وطبعا اول
ما خلص حلاقه يعني جاء ومسك الماكينه وقال
لي يلا خليته بالفعل يحلق لي شعري ونحنا
بنسوي هذا الموضوع قلت ليلام عباده خذي
لنا
صوره اخذنا الصوره هذه وخلاص يعني كان اخر
اليوم وانا كنت على وشك اني انام حطيت
الصوره في انستغرام وحطيت عليها الهاشتاج
اللي هو سمايل فور اوبي وطلبت من الناس
قلت لهم يعني اذا يعني اذا ممكن اذا انت
اصلع او شعرك خفيف انك تحلق وتحط صوره في
الانستغرام وتقول انه يا عباد انا شفت
شعرك وسويت
زيك
صحيت ثاني يوم لقيت الصوره هذه انتشرت
انتشار يعني مهول انا ما كنت متوقع ابدا
وصارت تجيني رسائل من كل الناس ومراسلين
يكلموني
و ويعني والحمد لله لقات تقريبا 50 شخص
رسلوا لي صورهم وبعضهم رسلوا فيديوهات
يخاطبوا عباده ويقولوا له عباده شفناك
حلقت شعرك وسوينا
زيك
طبعا الظريف في الموضوع الظريف في الموضوع
انه عباده لما شاف هذا الموضوع اثر عليه
بشكل ايجابي قوي جدا لدرجه انه سار يمشي
معايا في الشارع وكل ما يشوف شخص اصلع
يقول بابا هذا بيسوي زيي اكيد شافني
وبيسوي
زيي فالحمد لله ويعني وعدت هذيك
الفتره انتوا الان اكيد بتتساب بتقولوا
يعني ما شاء الله عليك وما شاء الله الله
يشفيلك عباده وكل حاجه وكذا بس يعني نحنا
كمستمع ايش ايش يخص الموضوع انا الحمد لله
ولادي طيبين وما عندنا اي حاجه انا حاقول
لك مجموعه اشياء انا في يوم من الايام كنت
شخص مثلي مثلك وكانت حياتي سعيده وكنت
مبسوط باولادي وكنت اروح شغلي وارجع وما
كان عندي اي مشاكل وفي يوم وليله وجيت
نفسي ابن اب لابني مريض السرطان انا ما
بفاول على احد فيكم الله يحميكم جميعا
ويحمي اولادكم من كل شر
ولكن مرض اللوكيميا لا يختار بين ذكر
وانثى بين عربي او غير عربي بين غني او
فقير بين اي ناس مرض لوكيميا الاطفال من
اكثر الامراض عشوائيه في اختيار
الضحايا فاذا لا سمح الله في يوم لقيت
نفسك في مكاني هناك مجموعه اشياء انت
تحتاج تحطها في بالك اولا لا تكون ضعيف
مثلي خليه قوي زي ام عباده ما شاء الله
عليها من يوم ما
شخصت فهي من يوم ما شخصت شخص ابني بالمرض
وهي ما القران وبتقرا ليل
نهار ثاني شيء الله لا يكتب على احد لكن
حجيك حجيك ايام حتشوف ابنك قليل الحيله
وما يقدر على الحراك وما تقدر تسوي لله اي
حاجه غير انك انت تطول فيه وتدعي الله انه
ربنا
يشفيه فالله يربط على
قلوبكم وفي مجموعه اشياء لازم اقول لكم هي
كابو وكا اخوه او اطفال
لاخوه مريضي السرطان اول حاجه طفلك اذا
جاله لوكيميا هو ليس طفل ميت اي نعم حتجي
له ايام هو ما حيقدر يتحرك من سريره ولكن
لما يصير هذا الشيء لا تحاول انك تقول له
ترى ما فيك شيء لا انت بتدلع لا ترى
العلاج بالفعل يهلك طاقه الطفل تماما حتجي
ايام ثانيه حيكون نشيط ويتحركوا وكل حاجه
لما يجي هذا اليوم ارجوك لا تحرموا من
قراءه الكتاب من لعبه بالعابه من زياره
الاصدقاء من شوفته لاخوته وكل الناس اللي
حواليه طبعا انتم اليوم ممكن بتفكروا الان
طيب ايش اخبار عباده كيف حاله الان انا
ابشركم عباده اولا موجود بيننا هنا جالس
في واحد من
الكراسي
والحمد لله ابتسامه عباده لا تزال في وجهه
وما فارقته بالرغم من كل اللي هو عدى فيه
بل بابتسامته هذه صار عنده اصحاب من كل
انحاء العالم من امريكا من الصين من
اليابان من اوروبا من افريقيا من كل انحاء
العالم والحمد
لله عباده ومدرسته مشكوره على هذا
الجهد صارت تفتحله ابواب مدرستها في اي
يوم حتى بعد الدراسه عشان يروح هناك ويحس
ان هو ما انحرم من مدرسته فلذلك انا شاكر
لهم وزي ما انتم شايفين في الصوره هو لابس
سبايدر مان وهو بطل يعني عايش حياته
البطله
اليوم عباد اليوم يلهم كثير من الناس ولكن
اكثر شخص بهمه
وقدوته
هو انا انا والحمد لله كنت ابحث عن قدوه
اتبعها طول حياتي وما كنت ادري انه في يوم
من الايام القدوه هذه حتكون طفلي عمر ذو
اربع
سنوات فقبل ما اختم حكايتي انا عندي
مجموعه نقاط بس حبيب اقولها معكم اولا لا
تنسوا لما يجيك طفل اذا مرض طفلك بالسرطان
لا تنسوا اخوته ترى اخوته احيانا ممكن
يصلوا لدرجه انهم من قله الاهتمام بهم
يقولوا يا بابا ليش عباده بس طب ليش ما حد
يهتم في ليش ما احد بيجيب لي انا هدايا
حاول انك تكون حريص في المساواه بين
ابنائك عشان لا يجيك الطفل السليم ويقول
يا ريت انا اللي كان عندي لوكيميا الله
يحمي
الجميع الشيء الثاني اكيد وانتم داخلين
شفتوا الصناديق اللي في المدخل والان
عرفتوا هي المين هي العباده والاخت ملك
انتم ما شاء الله حضور كبير فلو كل واحد
فيكم كتب رساله لعباده اتوقع يعني حتغير
من نفسيته كثير ولا تنسوا تحطوا اخته معه
عشان لا تحس انها هي
مهمله انا شاكر لكم شاكر لكم استماعكم
واتمنى يكون عباده الهمكم زي ما الهمني
واللي حابب يتابع قصه عباده ممكن يتابعها
في الهاشتاج سمايل فوبي شكرا لكم شكرا
جزيلا
ا